j'ai 5 enfants tous des adolescents
[Musique]
dans 10 ans oui
les cinq ensemble
mais tu sais faire autre chose au moins
j'ai rien fait d'autre et j'ai
l'impression que je ne sais rien faire
d'autre et ça me terrorise ce qui me
vient instinctivement c'est
l'enseignement plutôt à l'aise avec les
gens les enfants ça me connaît donc
voilà je me dis que ça pourrait
peut-être me ressembler les enfants vont
m'accorder 2 minutes j'ai quelque chose
à vous dire
j'étais malade non non je vais bien non
je me suis inscrite à l'université
je vais être honnête avec vous j'envoie
arrivé à chaque rentrée des étudiants de
votre âge et les trois quarts je ne vois
pas aller au bout peux-tu nous en a pas
parlé plus tôt c'est une décision que
j'avais besoin de prendre avec moi-même
je t'aiderai moi aussi j'aurais pu les
voir que ça fait donc je vais avoir du
temps on va faire comme si tu n'avais
jamais prononcé cette phrase
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que vous
attendez moi j'ai envie d'être à la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
route